Je sais pas si vous avez remarqué mais quand on retire de la thune aux distributeurs ça se passe toujours comme ça
Vous êtes sérieux là ? Vous croyez vraiment que j'ai fait une vidéo sur dépenser de l'argent
bah ouais je vais pas faire toute ma vie uniquement des vidéos sur les petites actions du quotidien
hein, déjà je crois que j'en ai fait beaucoup
et puis au bout d'un moment j'ai un petit peu envie d'autre chose j'ai envie de me diversifier
m'épanouir je pense que ça peut se comprendre donc non cette vidéo n'est pas une vidéo sur dépenser de l'argent
bon je pense qu'en cherchant sur youtube vous en trouverez peut-être mais je vais vous parler un petit peu de ce que je fais en ce
moment
de ce que je vous prépare et naturellement ce pourquoi je fais un petit peu moins de vidéos ces derniers temps elle même si je
compte bien en refaire plein plein très bientôt
Excuse moi, juste une petite remarque par rapport à ce que tu dis
bon c'est bien cet avis et tout mais
on s'en bat les couilles
bah non je suis pas d'accord je pense que contrairement à ce que tu dis les gens ça les intéresse aussi de
ben de connaître un peu mes projets artistiques tout ça quoi alors je me permets d'intervenir mais je pense qu'il a raison
on s'en bat les couilles bah ouais tes abonnés ils veulent une vidéo marrante, du divertissement
enfin pas du blabla quoi hein
Bon en tout cas moi ça me fait plaisir de partager un peu mes projets artistiques avec vous parce que on dirait pas forcément comme
ça mais bah la création c'est ma passion et ça occupe toute ma vie en fait donc je vais pouvoir vous en parler et puis
teaser un petit peu sur ce qui arrive bon on en vient à la grande nouvelle
hein la plus grande nouvelle de toute ma vie
bien plus importante que youtube bien plus importante que tout l'univers du moins pour moi je vous l'annonce officiellement
désormais je suis papa
What
C'est la plus belle chose au monde je suis je suis hyper heureux c'est un truc de ouf
du moins ça doit être un truc de ouf parce que pour tout vous dire je tourne cette vidéo avant le jour j
histoire ne pas être dérangé pendant que je devrais m'occuper de ce petit être c'est beaucoup de changements dans ma vie j'ai je
dois tout repenser c'est juste tellement de responsabilités
ça je le sais et en même temps tellement de bonheur bref j'en reparlerai pas tous les quatre matins
parce que c'est ma vie privée qui n'appartient qu'à moi et ma famille
mais je trouve ça important de vous le dire parce que déjà c'est une donnée cruciale
dans ma vie et ma carrière entre guillemets et puis ça me fait plaisir de vous l'annoncer quoi alors je souhaite me consacrer à 100%
à cette nouvelle vie sans pour autant arrêter les vidéos ou les projets artistiques mais quoi qu'il en soit il faut savoir que
mon rôle de père un peu bizarre de dire ça ce sera évidemment ma priorité
maintenant que cette info cruciale a été dite je reviens un peu dans l'artistique
si en ce moment je suis moins présent sur youtube c'est aussi parce que je prépare mon deuxième spectacle depuis plus de six mois je
l'écris et je le joue quasiment tous les soirs au panamarc café
ma salle de stand-up de prédilection c'est là que j'ai écrit mon premier
spectacle c'est la famille tous mes potos humoristes ils jouent d'ailleurs vous venez quand vous voulez c'est gratuit
juste je crois le prix d'une conso, par contre,  réservez à l'avance parce que c'est complet tous les soirs dont je mets les petites infos
ce spectacle j'y consacre énormément de temps et d'investissement et beaucoup de coeur
maintenant je suis si fier du résultat et de pouvoir le jouer pour vous sur scène
j'espère qu'il, ben,  rassemblera autant de gens que pour le premier, vous étiez 400 000 à venir le voir donc
encore merci pour ça surtout que celui-ci je risque de le jouer pour les francophones de plein de pays du monde
bref j'en dis pas plus je vous dirai à plus tard en tout cas en exclusivité voici la fiche de ce nouveau spectacle
ouais elle est en work in progress
pour l'instant j'ai 35 minutes de spectacle sur scène
donc
ça avance bien et j'en profite pour caler une petite date exceptionnelle que je fais à la cigale avec plein de poteaux humoriste je vous mets
les infos ici ce sera en avril j'ai plus pensé mais je au montage je serai tout va bien les gars
moi ça va on sait juste un peu chier mais vas-y continue mais il fait quoi l'autre
à lui l'écart en partie un effet une pause il a appuyé en a foutre un super bon
s'enrichissent toujours
ok je continue et j'ai l'honneur d'avoir été contacté par une grosse plateforme de vidéos dont la première lettre est la même que la première
lettre de mon prénom nous y ait eu une hideuse ls
On encore travailler sur un programme
à la fois à scénariser et en même temps un peu improvisé
complètement cool pour être honnête c'est vraiment l'un des projets qui m'excite le plus en ce moment donc j'espère que ça va se faire je
croise les doigts
Football en parallèle avec wedia on développe une série de science fiction que j'avais écrite il ya un an et demi en fait et qu'on
reprend que maintenant c'est un projet très ambitieux sur plusieurs épisodes
je passe tout seul de réaliser un coauteur avec moi et tout alors je me suis lâché 1
l'histoire ça se passe légèrement dans le futur intense à un lien peu avec notre époque
bref je pas trop en dire pour pas spoiler un peu frustrant mais vous verrez bien on sait pas encore à quelle diffuseur ça va
être destinée donc que peut-être une plateforme de vidéo peut-être
Qui m'importe c'est d'écrire une belle histoire qui me plaît après le reste bon d'accord donc je fais que des projets en dehors de youtube
superbe c'est quoi je démissionne c'est quoi voilà
C'est vraiment parce que j'ai aujourd'hui
Je reprends je vous rassure la suite concerne uniquement youtube il ya pas mal de trucs donc
mais comment que j'avais fait avec ludovic mon court métrage le bloc des 10 millions que j'avais adoré faire et que vous aviez je crois
beaucoup aimé aussi c'est la vidéo dont je suis le plus fier de toute ma chaîne vous et il paraît que vous êtes le spécialiste
mois le compteur de ma chaîne youtube est bloqué je sais plus quoi faire à combien 9 millions 999
vous avez dit combien eh ben on recolle à bord ensemble pour une série sur la chaîne youtube
donc pour vous le même style que le bol des 10 millions avec une toute nouvelle histoire
donc uran sans doute plein de poteaux de youtube dedans et d'ailleurs donc ça c'est bien cool j'ai bien hâte de tourner ça
d'ailleurs tout est écrit là y'a plus qu'à tourner je prépare aussi pour ma chaîne youtube un tout nouveau court métrage
que je fais avec cyprien qui mêle à la fois des prises de vues de fiction classique et en même temps
autre chose mais ça c'est une surprise si je le dis ça ça casse tout le concept donc je je ne dis rien
désolé c'est un peu la vidéo de la frustration puisque je ne dis rien je ne montre rien mais bon moi je t'annonce bon ben
voilà c'est pas mal ça enfin du contenu youtube des promesses des promesses
j'attends de voir un bon allez je préfère une petite vidéo de mcfly car les tôles à cette partie
de la voir justement énorme dans un tout autre style j'ai lancé sur ma chaîne youtube
mon petit concept une journée avec j'ai fait le premier épisode avec jamie et en a plein d'autres qui sont en préparation je veux faire
ça uniquement avec des gens que j'aime bien à des artistes ou personnalités
que j'admire en mélangeant des moments de vie et des petites interviews un peu détendus d'ailleurs le prochain invité je peux vous le dire
allez petit teaser subliminal
D'accord donc en fait tu deviens le nouveau laurent boyer quoi c'est qui laurent boyer
c'est ça ton projet moi je connais thierry boyer mais
évidemment tous ces projets bas et coûte très cher
surtout quand ils sont nombreux faut bien les financer et parfois j'ai finance entièrement de ma propre poche
son retour sur investissement et ça me fait plaisir par exemple mon court métrage le bug des 10 millions je vous balance le chiffre 1
il a coûté
70 mille euros et pourrait transport avec vous les vieux tubes sa rembourse
absolument pas un mais quand c'est pour un projet artistique qui me tient à coeur
bah je suis prêt à le faire et je suis très content un taux va bien mais du coup parfois
ça peut m'arriver de faire une petite vidéo sponsorisés pour m'aider à
financer ce genre de projet vent du jeu pour avoir un pourcentage ou bon je crois que c'est le moment de faire une petite conclusion
enfin
même si je sais que les vidéos un peu classique que j'ai toujours fait ce que certains appellent les podcasts va vous plaisent énormément
chez que d'autres aiment un peu moins paradoxalement c'est les vidéos qui font le plus de vue donc
les gens ont un avis différent
ce qui fait aussi la richesse des viewers je suis toujours à l'écouté de vos commentaires que je lis qui souvent sont très constructif et
plein d'amour
Je vous rassure un heureusement y'a pas que ça j'essaye de lire tous vos avis et puis d'en tenir compte le plus possible c'est aussi
pour ça que je fais cette vidéo c'est pour vous parler avoue mois dans tout ça
ben faut aussi que je trouve ma place que je fasse des choses qui me plaisent qui m'intéresse vraiment au final ça se ressent quand
une vidéo elle n'est pas sincère de thé des fois je fais des vidéos parce qu'il faut produire du contenu absolument sur youtube ça marche
comme ça et puis vous le ressentez en fait ça vous plaît pas et moi non plus tout vous dire parfois je tourne une vidéo
je la regardais fait tiens c'est de la merde et quelques semaines par exemple j'ai fait une vidéo un podcast
sur la mode et ça a donné
ça il ya des gens qui sont
obsédés par les marques de fringues est vraiment que ça qui compte pas du tout le reste du vêtement
Mais en même temps c'est
Vraiment le gâcher autant le trimestre et de 10,6 en même temps c'est vrai qu'il m'a dit tu ne rentres aux non
Pas parce que t'as pas même si comme nous comprend et d'être avec toi
La prochaine fois qu'on sort ont tapé surtout si on va chez darty
N'était pas assez bien à mon goût alors finalement gelée par claude et j'ai perdu du temps
de l'énergie de l'argent mais voilà c'est ça aussi la création
prendre des risques parfois se tromper et
recommencer donc parfois on pensait que je fais rien mais je fais des trucs c'est juste que je ne mets pas en ligne parce que
c'est trop nul
moi j'adore bosser pour rien en fait c'est ça un plaisir alors même si j'adore faire les vidéos sur les petits trucs du quotidien comme
par exemple faire à manger si je vous jure j'adore faire cette vidéo repérée des petites choses de la vie quotidienne et qui
m'amuse et puis les mettre ensemble et voulait partager c'est un truc qui me plaît beaucoup depuis toujours que je fais d'ailleurs à la fois
en vidéo est aussi un peu sur scène
donc je vais continuer à faire sur deux vidéos et en même temps j'ai envie de nouveauté envie de me diversifier
envie de m'épanouir dans ce que je fais même si je me suis déjà un peu diversifiée en faisant des fictions tf1 qu
développe des clips des rencontres mais j'ai encore envie de
nouveauté donc désolé pour ce petit laps de temps ma chaîne youtube est moins fournie en contenu je pense qu'en regardant cette vidéo
vous comprenez un peu pourquoi j'en profite pour vous remercier d'être là après tant d'années
dix ans bientôt le temps passe tellement vite je le dis ici parce que finalement j'ai assez rarement l'occasion de le faire dans un sketch
une fiction vous êtes 11 millions trois cent soixante mille
franchement j'ai jamais réussi à réaliser ce chiffre mais en tout cas ce que je sais c'est que aujourd'hui
depuis pas mal de temps maintenant là je vis la vie dont j'ai toujours rêvé
et ça je dois uniquement à vous qui a gardé mes vidéos et qui venait à mes spectacles
donc merci du fond du coeur pour ça je vous dois tout et je veux me battre pour continuer à produire des vidéos ou des
créations à la hauteur de ce que vous attendez le plus longtemps possible en m'adaptant à ce que vous aimez tout en essayant de vous
surprendre et en m'épanouissant aussi moi même et je vous promets que je le ferai parce que depuis toujours passer avant tout ma passion
Qu'est ce qu'il t'arrive Colin, tu pleurs ?
J'sais pas j'ai une conjonctivite d'un coup là
bon ok ok j'ai pleuré j'ai pleuré avec tes conneries là
Ah merde bah désolé j'ai dit ce que je pensais c'est tout
bon finalement j'aurais peut-être dû faire une vidéo sur dépenser de l'argent en fait foi
Oh